hey guys it's justine and i am so
excited because i just got this massive
delivery of a new traeger timberline xl grill i
have been working on redoing my patio and when
you see the before and after it's been a pretty
extensive makeover and this is the final piece
in the patio makeover that i was waiting for
and it's here and now it's time to set it up
the last time i did an unboxing it was for
my parents we got them one of the traeger
girls so now i'm so excited i have one of
my very own so the unboxing process is well
we've got a very big box so let's let's do it
here we go yeah we're moving and grooving now
like these are holding this whole box together
like it's pretty much together is it the right
way oh yeah it is the right way oh this is
exciting wow it's beautiful where are those
instructions at are you in there i bet they're in
here oh more things i was just looking around for
somebody else to put this together but it's me
and jake this is it we we don't have anyone else
nice love to see it love it oh oh
i hope these are just empty boxes
these are not empty boxes there are in fact items
inside the wheels are here start your journey
here i took another path on my journey so um if
you're on the same journey that i'm on you might
want to open the box that was on the top first the
first thing that we have to do is tip this over so
that we put the wheels on it and this is where
i'm going to need some assistance jake please
ah shoot your fingers watch your
thingies they are number or letter b
look at that
this looks right right no it's upside down
yep it is i we're technically like almost done
and if that's the case then these are the
two missing screws that i need we've got some
accessories i'm so excited because there's so
many different things that you can get for this
we're still building but all that's left now are
the accessories and to get it all set up on wi-fi
so i'm so excited to actually start grilling
i thought i was gonna be able to grill tonight
but i'm getting tired so tomorrow will be the big
grill out day i've invited some of my friends over
and they're going to enjoy my cooking well
i'm going to i'm going to make them enjoy it
so it's all put together i'm going to do all
of the setup process get this hooked up to my
phone get it connected to wi-fi and do the
cleaning process so tomorrow it'll be time
to grill i'm so excited do you like steak uh do
you like burgers i do do you like chicken i do
like beef yeah great because that's what's
on the menu this is the newest traeger model
that is more versatile and convenient than the
previous models it comes with meter wireless
probes and an outdoor induction cooktop so you
won't have to go inside to use a stove top it
has configurable storage and accessories with easy
cleanup cutting board 22 pound stay dry pellet bin
a new grease management system that collects
grease and ash a grilling lights and even
more grilling surface than ever before it is an
exciting day it's grill day and the meat cave
my friends is all set up this morning the first
thing that i did was get it all ready i did the
seasoning and i've almost tripped on my wood
pallets which is incredible because i already
have one of the bags inside of here which is where
you put the pellets and that's what actually fires
this grill good morning it's day of the big grill
out and i have to season the grill i'm getting
everything prepped i just woke up but i want to
get this seasoned and get everything all clean
so i can start prepping so the first thing it's
telling me to do is add the pellets so let's do it
ignite my grill another thing that
i love so much about this type of
grill is you can use it not only to grill
but you can use it for smoking and baking
like you can actually make muffins there's
recipes inside of the app that shows you
all of these things that you can make and i
am by no means a grilling or cooking expert
and if you're new on my channel here well
go watch some of my old cooking videos
but the thing that i love so much about this
is traeger has a ton of educational resources
in their app they have traeger tv so i can go
and watch all sorts of recipes get inspiration
and even go through and this will give you
step-by-step recipes of all sorts of different
things like this week their recipes they have a
moroccan spiced roast chicken red curry salmon
and a baked halibut sandwich with smoked tartar
sauce wow that sounds incredible also something
cool about traeger is they have a ton of
accessories and they also have some spices
and some sauces this is the traeger q barbecue
sauce and we actually went out and got this this
morning we did an online order at a local retailer
these i found all at ace hardware and ordered them
online and jake who's behind the camera here he
picked them up and brought them here for us to
start our grilling process i don't even
remember what i bought i just kind of went
to whole foods and was like burgers steaks kebabs
yes please also excited to cook some vegetables
this is a nice little traeger vegetable tray
that we got with the grill this is really cool
this is the induction stovetop so it's a little
accessory that just connects to the grill not
only does it connect wirelessly through bluetooth
but it also connects with the power to the grille
so you don't have to have any additional power
accessories and this is great because if you do
want to make something on the stovetop a lot
of times you'd have to go back inside but now
you don't have to because it is right here next
to your grill i just love that everything works
together and it's just so convenient i can't wait
to get cooking another thing that i love so much
are these little pop and lock accessories so these
are just like these little hooks that you can get
and those just snap right into place and over
here is this little roll bar so you can put
paper towel they also have some trigger meat paper
wraps that you can get i decided to put some foil
here because i have a feeling that we're gonna
need some foil for all of the things that we're
making today i love this tray this just lifts up
and it folds down but this is another one of the
pop and lock accessories that just goes right
on this little ledge right there these are the
bluetooth meat thermometers i already have them
connected to the grill it's so easy you just go
in and you add accessories here on the lcd oh
let me just find a new home for them maybe here
on these beautiful wooden shelving i love
this color combination too like this black
and this light brown love that you know what
i can do i can put these in here look at this
a perfect fit i love that okay check this out
this is where the pellets go and you just dump
those in there there's also a pellet sensor so
you'll be able to know if this is running low
and one of the notes that they have been
very adamant about is making sure that you
don't leave these in here for a long amount of
time if you're not going to be using them that
could affect the pellets ability to help
you grill to perfection definitely want
to keep those away from humidity which links
us under here we've got this little container
which we can put all of our pellets in when we're
not using them this is also great because they've
got little stickers they have tons of different
types of flavors the one that we're using now is
the natural flavored hardwood and they have
these little icons right here that show you
what it's recommended for and thankfully this one
is good with anything which is great because we
are making a wide variety of things today we gotta
start doing some kitchen prep also while shooting
this video the fire pit that i got which was
basically like the two last parts that i needed
for this patio redo was the grill and the fire
pit and it's here so my sister's gonna come over
help put that together this is gonna be the best
impromptu grill out that i've ever had i've never
actually had one before so it's actually my first
my first grill out are you excited oh my god
yes this is cool let's go prep the meat so we've
got all of our things prepared to take out to
the grill we've got burgers cauliflower steak
we've got some beef kebabs we've got some filets
potatoes we've got some chicken kebabs
they still have to prep so let's get to it
food is prepped friends are on their way the
grill is now going to get preheated and we are
about to drop on the meat and veggies i love this
lcd because basically you can control everything
through here so we just turned and pressed the
dial to set grill temperatures we're gonna set
to 400 ready to ignite oh we have liftoff we have
liftoff make sure to keep your grates drip tray
okay everything is clean because you're brand new
this all connects to the app so i'm able to keep
an eye on the heat and i can even adjust things
like the temperature so i can keep it warm or
i can even shut it down so now we wait and i'll
go get our goods so to show you guys before and
after of this back patio it was full of weeds it
was disgusting it was so terrible and now this is
the transformation it is finally complete we've
got our fire pits and we've got our grill and
i could not be more excited they did such
a great job they kind of took my vision
i wanted like this rock wall with succulents they
told me that i probably would kill the succulents
in there so we're gonna put some fake ones in
which i'm a-okay with but we've got some really
cool planters we've got some plants all around
the outer perimeter but this rock wall was my
favorite piece of it we've got these little
market lights as well that connect to the rock
wall the sun will be going down soon so you'll be
able to see the ambiance now it is time to cook
first meat on wait i need i'm gonna put
it over here because i want to stick the
temperature sensor in it no we're jamming this
in there when cooking internal temperatures
yes
these are jalapeno burgers
get ready for the meat the induction soap
is something i'm so excited to try out i've
got my cast iron pan here and we are going to
cook up the asparagus so we just put this on
and then we're going to turn it all the way
up to turbo just to kind of get it started
and you can notice the color
change here that turns orange
and it'll show you where in the heat range
you're at of course i'll just dump them in
i could do these in the grill but for the sake of
testing purposes we're making
use of the induction stove
so we're gonna take our first little peek see
how they're doing oh yeah these are looking great
so everything looks pretty good we just received
the internal temperature warning on this
steak so we're going to flip them looking very
good okay burgers you're getting flipped that
looks incredible there's cheese on it so that's
going to be leaking cheese through the bottom
steaks are done everyone i
can't believe it i cannot i
am just as shook as you grab yourself a plate
our first delivery has been made of our steaks
and now i'm gonna test one out for myself while
the burgers and chicken continue to cook i like
mine usually pretty well done so this is perfect
it's really hot oh yeah and the rub that we
put on this too is so good i'm a happy camper
looks like our chicken is also
done time to serve the guests
this has like a chili flake rub on it let's try
this one huh oh i think i like that one even warm
that's nice yeah that's really good you want
pieces of chicken kebab i do yeah hand it out here
that's really it's nice it's on there oh
this is really good yeah yeah big fan i'll
tell you what this trigger key though
look at that it's like a chicken nugget
night you're allergic to chicken so i folded
the cheese in so it doesn't drip down there's
a little bit mess here here put it put it in
put it in we're losing we're losing fire yep
put it in put it in there bye-bye little
grilled cheese jenna doesn't eat meat
so she made herself a grilled cheese the
cauliflower was really good but i just was
still hungry i'm sorry cheese i'm just gonna push
all this stuff off to the side because now it's
time to bake cookies you can actually use this
grill to bake jenna my dear sister has prepped us
with some cookies that are basically already
made we just kind of pop them on the pan look
they're gluten free too alrighty look at these
cookies oh my god these look so good it's like
okay so gluten-free will be over here so one two
three four five six so we'll do six on the side
let's go put them on the grill it got
dark real quick out there it is time now
cookies are going in close them up
the grilled cheese i think
it's ready yeah look i had
to scoot it over because oops it was going
into the chocolate cookies on the bottom
oh oh nice you wanna bite i've
got such an interesting buffet of
meal really bad oh my god that's actually so good
i didn't put any butter on her neither it has like
a little smoked flavor from the the pellets yeah
it's quite nice i was gonna bring tomato soup
next time same brain this is actually
really good who would would've thought me
drum roll please the cookies
i think they're done it's getting so dark out
here i can't actually see these look so good
take a look at those i'm gonna put a little
sea salt on some do you want some sea salt sure
they actually look really good i'm pretty
impressed well that concludes the video thank
you guys so much for watching i had so much fun
getting a chance to use this new traeger grill
and i got to make some chocolate
chip cookies let's try them
oh my gosh it's perfect maddie i would let you try
this but you're a dog and you can't have chocolate
thank you again to traeger for partnering
with me on this video this was incredible
i look forward to doing some more grilling
now that the patio is finally complete i
can't breathe because i've eaten so much
meat like i'm literally gasping for air
you guys want to get more information about
the timberline xl grill i'll put a link in
the description and i will see you guys in
my next video peace out oh god jenna you
gotta get in on this cookie action it's very
hot it is hot it's so good yeah it's too hot
you're fine all right cookies are ready
kids come and get them get that cookie
you